est-ce que vous pensez que vous avez les
mêmes possibilités que les garçons pour
devenir ingénieur
pour
le devenir et dans la vie
professionnelle avec le monde des
adultes
on est fortement défavorisés
pour faire la cuisine s'occuper des
enfants et beaucoup de gens beaucoup
d'hommes le pensent nous sommes sur un
chantier avec le casque les bottes
marchandes dans la boue est-ce que c'est
pas un peu curieux comme silhouette
comme personnage non on a autant
d'aptitudes que les garçons
c'est un exemple bien précis il y a
vraiment beaucoup d'autres choses
différentes dans la carrière d'ingénieur
mais est-ce que vous pensez que vous
pouvez à la fois être en arrière avoir
des enfants et travailler à temps plein
dans ce métier d'ingénieur qui est quand
même un métier difficile
[Musique]
très peu de matériel alors il faut
qu'elle ait qu'elle sache s'organiser
évidemment c'est c'est un problème le
plus pour les femmes il faut qu'elle
s'impose toujours à tous les moments de
leur vie aussi bien pour commencer des
études pour travailler